[Musique]
comédienne vous intéresse ou pas
pourquoi moi c'est quelqu'un qui est
vraiment hors circuit qui se maintient
pas comme elle peut mais bon j'ai pas
d'antipathie particulière pour elle mais
ni de sympathie physiquement vous la
trouvez comment un bon jeu cette fois
physique j'apprécie beaucoup
elle est plus côté à l'argus elle est
allée voir sa prochaine pièce pas du
tout - ne l'a pas trouvé comment je
pense qu'elle est plus rapide un choc
violent du premier là je peux pas croire
que j'en dise ça toi n'ont fait qu'ils
sont bourrés mon avis je sais pas il ya
anguille sous roche
as tu crois je pense que c'est de
l'intox je pense que celle d'intel soit
peu petit mais chantons commun on va
voir
alors on va voir sur qui portait la
question est pour cheyrou de line renaud
une renault monsieur que pensez vous de
lire no comment que pensez-vous de line
renaud
on applaudit l'ironie au lieu de nous
excuser moi non plus parler des
guillemets ça m'a rassuré quand même
[Musique]
est ce que vous connaissez anémone la
comédienne à peine de non dits
j'appréciais ah oui est ce que votre
avis là et d'avoir été la première dame
de france dans sa carrière pour faire du
cinéma
est-ce que vous l'appréciez c'est très
court selon la presse il dit je n'aime
pas les gens viennent pour les bulgares
dont elle a aidé représentative de
l'ensemble du
couches sociales enfin très répandu
finalement est-ce que ça l'a aidé
d'avoir été la maîtresse de valéry
giscard d'estaing pour démarrer sa
carrière va travailler pendant un an
valéry giscard d'estaing et tire et ça
l'a propulsé est ce que ça vous choque
mais ça ne m'intéresse pas je me sens à
des années lumière d'une personne pareil
nouvelle faute de goût du matin en vous
habillant pas du tout moi la femme d'un
président et et tourner un film
nullement ça me choque
anémone elle vous choque le sam est
chaud regarde aller sur le plateau dit
lui anémone auditrice vous en pensez
enfin ne sais pas sur quoi sur le fait
qu'elle ait fait des films nu alors
qu'elle était la première dame de france
la première dame de france faire des
films nu pour nous a appris que vraiment
c'est choquant moi je ne pense pas voilà
c'est ce que j'ai à dire regardez les
sur le gâteau tous les moyens sont bons
pour accéder à la célébrité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà vous connaissez brigitte lahaie
brigitte lahaie et là c'est la femme de
jean luc
le chanteur vous connaissez brigitte
lahaie oui y est une actrice une actrice
une actrice de film porno je crois quand
même faut y aller il met trois fois et
les uns et qu'est ce qu'elle est devenue
aujourd'hui aucune idée aucune idée ça
va pas bien brillant mais je ne sais pas
trop
ça fait plus de télé ça coûte plus j'en
sais rien la dénommée ce matin
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse et aux
sports
[Musique]
non vous plaisantez un des tous est
tombée ce matin
vu comme va la france ça m'étonnerait
guère coiffé tout à fait possible si
koné un score à votre avis aux sports au
lit ou aux livres hébraïques honnête il
sur les marchés le matin est loin des
poireaux sur les marchés aujourd'hui
vous le saviez
non du tout ça vous étonne
vous voyez pas de sot métier non mais
vous trouvez que c'est la suite logique
de ce qu'elle faisait avant alors pas du
tout dans le poireau baril attendu
allait rentrer dans les ordres à les
religieuses dans un couvent dans le lot
et elle s'appelle soeur brigitte en
costume de religieuses ou qu'on sait
qu'elle pourrait vous donner encore des
idées
alors oui certainement c'était quand
même une belle femme
il m'est arrivé de rêver d'elle même
j'ai déjà palucher regardant le cas ces
deux là n'ont jamais nous venons vous
savez ce qu'elle est devenue aujourd'hui
non pas du tout non j'ai été nommé ce
matin ministre de la condition féminine
ob c'est super pourquoi pas après tout
oui c'est une [ __ ]
enfin disons qu'elle a fait des films
pornos duel ministre alors si vous la
croisez demain vous allez l'appeler
madame la ministre ou vieille [ __ ]
purina la ministre
buts autant pour ma part en ministre
genre dépit ce matin c'est pas possible
puis ce matin mais pas françois
mitterrand avec décennies comme ça n'a
pas un conseil des ministres un homme
habillé c'est vrai mais avec tout ce
qu'elle a fait don reçu suite à ça son
passé et je crois pas je pense pas jan
bucquoy
vous savez les titres des chansons qui a
bu boira même tout et même si elle est
devenue ministre juge difficile et des
gosses qui a dû bois qui a vu moi
j'attends tes à sa personne à m parce
que ça subordonne tout un pack cursus de
carrière qui est pas sans arrière-pensée
ce qui fait que vous êtes une bande de
pornographie et de dégueulasse facho
merci beaucoup merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose qui est certaine c'est
tantôt mardi que tu as été nommé
ministre de la condition féminine quoi
le jour sont pas spécialement étonné tu
vois comme quoi notre époque quand même
sous qui a encore du pain sur la planche
il ya du pain sur la planche payera
qu'ils le croient tout ce qui était plus
crédible s'était mise de l'intérieur de
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que pensez-vous des charlotte de
turckheim un des charlotte de turckheim
cette comédienne la japonaise a trouvé
comment physiquement j'étais un bonhomme
physiquement faut vraiment se prononcer
pas terrible quand même peut-être plus
moche non elle est pas belle mais est
excitante
ah ouais elle est pas belle mais alors
là oui ça vous dirait de tromper votre
pinceau avec elle si j'ai beau lui
rendre service elle a beaucoup de charme
comme fille comme un premier pas mal oui
bof à 10 ans et pour moi c'est madame
non non elle vraiment nul 7 mo farah
rien à dire c'est ne pas jouer ghislaine
al anon à dormir dehors
honnêtement ces moments-là bourges ou
est-ce que répressive autoritaire la
flèche être moi je peux pas quoi quatre
veulent toi ouais ouais elle est
mignonne à la décharge a vaincu le par
vous regardez les sur le plateau et elle
me dit qu'elle est très très attiré par
vous donc que lui répondez vous
bombay ciblés sais pas et puis pour ben
j'y vais ça pourra aller si haut ce
voyage deux fois mais elle voudrait
faire l'amour en égout il m'a dit dans
le casque est d'accord ou pas je ne
souhaite pas aussi bâtiment frères avoir
est une fable c'est juste pour nick et
elle me dit que rappaz de sentiments du
tout sédhiou pour moi parce que je suis
mieux
je vais le lire souvent quand saison
d'aventuré les phases s'attache beaucoup
normal c'est humain c'est tentant bon
donc même là je suis j'ai envie de vous
revoir c'est normal je suis une autre
qui a du mal à se quitter sa vacuité
tout bon ménage
si elle jure de ne pas s'accrocher est
ce que vous seriez prêt lui faire
l'amour
pourquoi cette fois ci quand même que à
s'occuper que sa sécurité
sediba guerra elle voudrait savoir quel
est votre spécialité
comment de
moussa
parlons là tout à l'heure je t'ai vu au
maquillage avec m en train de dire que
si tu avais fait l'émission c'est grâce
à lui c'est parce qu'il était là j'ai
fait une erreur j'ai fait une grave
erreur va changer la ville j'ai changé
d'avis et garçons 1re de poule ou d'asie
espèce de demi portions plus apte en
charge chirurgicale star de daniel sort
à la gta céline renaud quand j'ai
quelques stars de deux coaches cassel
qui se tapit mais le problème c'est que
j'ai montré ta photo ouais mais si tu
les a montées à des nazes si tu as vu la
tronche des macaques et la montre et je
t'ai dit que je ne sortais qu'avec des
baux verts sont si tu avais montré à des
beaux garçons ils auraient dit les
petites filles est super et tous les
guides amant qui les montent à des vieux
cons à des moustachus alors évidemment
on vaut mieux en qui me déçoit en
règlements entourant ses skis très fort
donc assez proche malade il a l'habitude
l'habitude
alors ça
très endetté
les embêter de ce co star de star bon ça
va je suis aussi très embêté parce qu'on
a parlé des yeux on a parlé du nez ouais
on oublier les ongles à les eaux ou
embêté parce que là j'ai donc tout
l'hyper me voir regarde c'est immonde
amis j'ai des très bons on t'a fait de
la bricole ah mais non justement c'est
parce qu'il se passe quoi que la tournée
sainement et donc est ce que cette virée
d'avoir à vis des ongles beau non je
m'en fous bon mais tu regardes pas alors
[Musique]
tenez vous aimez dorothée tient ou moins
réglé madame s'il vous plaît pour régler
quoi que dise que c'est 30 francs vous
ai rien demandé non mais je sais bien
c'est duarte camille cette technique de
vente au point assez de la vente directe
et alors alors on donnait dispose
enfants il part en les taillant 6 me
sentais qu'à ma chérie tu aimes dorothée
qu'un c'est pour toi
ses 33 ans madame c'est avant le direct
a maintenant prenez pas le droit de
reprendre le disque à l'enfant dorothée
matériaux de reprendre des essais
dorothée voilà un qui a mis cette
technique aux points
dorothée lé pa petit c'est ce qu'elle
fait c'est de retrouver quelque chose
comme ça aux jeunes débutants à main
puis je dire apprécié 30 francs et ses
200 c'est à dire c'est 30 francs oui
c'est une grande direct et dorothée
camille cette vente au point pour se
faire des couilles en or vous êtes
obligé vous l'avez tous chez madame j'ai
pas de monnaie je vous ordonne 3g pas de
monnaie alors je vous donne un club
dorothée j'avoue que l'engin pin 5g un
vibromasseur
est ce que je le stérilet dorothée qui
va sortir vous voulez quoi qu'est ce que
vous voulez aller jouer sur l'autoroute
les enfants alerte
dorothée n'aime pas les enfants alors
foutez lui la paix à dorothée 1
tiens c'est pour vous voilà non c'est 30
francs madame vous me réglez s'il vous
plaît j'ai pas loin de reprendre madame
dorothée m'interdit de reprendre les
disques que je donne aux enfants c'est
pas bon pour son image
c'est dorothée lycée technique aux
points tiens ma chérie c'est le ballon
vous êtes les chante avec vous en prie
il ya mon chéri c'est pourquoi j'ai pas
mal de reprendre vous mon but est de
régler s'il vous plaît mais
plaignez-vous à dorothée si vous n'êtes
pas contente
regardez vous laisser aller la faire
pleurer j'allais rentrer enfants
malheureux mais c'est dorothée camus
c'est pour ainsi pourquoi
n'empêche que ça rapporte du pognon et
c'est ça le principal elle est adéquat
lourd et c'est moi qui tu leur chute de
l'offre
je l'espérais de ma poche
[Applaudissements]
hu
alors laurent vais te dire la vérité
mais c'est à dire la vérité je pensais à
la suite de cette séquence te demander
de venir s'excuser mais je pense que la
réaction de retrait était quand même
beaucoup plus gros démarrage et un début
de réaction vote bravo tu dois te dis je
me mouille pas dans les sujets je crois
que j'aurais eu la bonne réaction
ah oui on applaudit dorothée voir la
navigation avait dit elle a des couilles
bon ben voilà qui violent mais ça va me
tuer ça va il plus 1000 victoires non je
suis très mouillé on
[Musique]
al amal sinistre boulot l'inde qui est
le
alors bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
appelée genre de réaction chez l'artiste
il est mort et elle a beaucoup que tu
meurs ok on va vous pourriez au moins
compatibles je sais pas moi on pourrait
non pas un ni faire d'une façon comme je
sais pas mais pas joué le jeu dit oh là
là quelle tristesse
versailles est humain quoi à leurs frais
monsieur eddy mitchell est mort à 15
heures dommage ce qu'on appelle un fan
de la première heure
j'aime eddy mitchell à l'époque des
chaussettes noires surtout -31 vous
ferez la part de sa disparition
aujourd'hui c'est un homme quand vous
dommage
c'est dommage mais c'est votre peine à
votre émotion monsieur aussi beaucoup je
vais bien et moi j'ai eu un accident de
chasse dans ses toilettes un accident de
voie de chasse dans ses toilettes
les as de la compagnie johnnie walker a
déjà perdu quatre points en bourse
la bougie connais assez d'effet immédiat
de la mort de d'eddy mitchell qui était
le plus gros consommateur de johnny
walker
bon ok ce qu'était ce qui était arrivé
comment s'est tiré une balle dans l'anus
aujourd'hui à 15h en voyant les scores
des ventes de patrick bruel n'a pas
supporté les records
pourquoi en balles dans la nuit après
nos cerveaux et en désespoir de cause
ils se tirent une balle dans la nuit
rien à vous lire eddy mitchell est mort
monsieur ça vous vous en foutez
j'aurais préféré que ce soit george
habache ci-contre le mon avis pas du
trou en ce qui concerne et démissionner
si vous n'êtes pas de mon avis la
question est réglée et à cri eddy
mitchell celui de la peine au dessus
signifie aussi vous allez prendre le
train ouais j'en ai volant mais vous
êtes bien curieux à ses journalistes un
monsieur alors vous vous adressiez un
officier de la légion d'honneur grand
commandeur de la légion d'honneur
alors qu'il est s'il vous plaît appelez
parce que moi aussi j'ai des pin's sir
cuts et pas des plis
on sait pas limpide mais il est
collector le vote joue les changes
je voulais change
[Applaudissements]
ce stade
bravo laurent déjà tu es nécrose
et bizarrement les gens aiment beaucoup
ça mais dans ce tetra dont les jambières
marcheurs par steve et on leur dit le
roi du rock'n'roll est mort dans un
premier temps et nous avons johnny après
on dit non non c'est dit il les gens
disent ah mais c'est peur raconte moi je
fais pas ça n'a pas coûté de façon non
au québec d'ici l'annoncé était mort de
rire
c'est des chansons que tout le monde
connaît la preuve baffier tollé dans la
rue vérifier
laurent baffie co star des stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous connaissez enrico macias
on va bien sûr ce serait bien heureux
citer au moins une de ses chansons
bon bah j'en connais plein multi chanson
devait alors attendez america
proviennent à l'idée la valider enrico
macias se connaît à koumassi à johnny
hallyday on dit ah non je n'ai aliens
moi je n'aime voir gelée la seybouse
yakoma siège l'a entendue chanter bien
qu'elle veut dire moi je les connais
tous petits chansons mais oui ou non
mais ils ne viennent pas l'idée est
distant validé madame enrico macias oui
je sais si tu es au moins une chanson
d'enrico macias et moi une chanson
d'enrico macias enfants de tous pays à
l'encontre non à l'idée je veux dire à
l'idée est dans la tête n'ont pas l'idée
madame enrico macias enfants de tous
pays
par sa sentence le collège cobast ya une
chanson
c'est stupide la bonne idée comme ça
walid et madame enrico macias et et vous
pouvez pas inviter mes de la paix sur la
loire où nous pourrons vous y êtes si tu
es moi une chanson d'enrico macias voilà
je z mais je peux même une à chanter
mais je ne suis pas du tout dans le coup
là pour toi et moi une chanson d'enrico
vos déchets je vais très sûre vous ne
connaissez pas quoi ci gît dans la poche
les connaissais tout je connais toutes
ces pratiques et quand même ça ne vient
pas là incapable de me citer une seule
chanson une enfant de toper alors que je
n'ai pas rapide des champions quand même
si ridicule et panne était au début de
tout pays ce sont entre conte pour
enfant écrit matthias enfin de tous pays
par ailleurs la connaît de tant de temps
si elle se sent très bon match à la
bombe theillet la vie de star des stars
[Applaudissements]
laurent baffie était allé voir les gens
dans la rue pour leur parler de
françoise hardy et l'astrologie est
prête à cet effet si tu entends
mouchoirs un oui je serre les dents
voilà l'ambiance
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour est ce que vous aimez françoise
hardy sur le plateau de double jeu âgé
quant à cette émission
quoi qu'il en soit et sur le plateau
maintenant elle ne chante plus se
consacrent exclusivement l'astrologie
est ce que vous voulez avoir salu des
plus rien parce que son grand frère
celle à arrêter donc à la suite de
l'exemple petit haut risque pour demain
vous aviez fait ses propres l'astrologie
elle dit pas de métro pour demain si
elle voit le catastrophe pour vous si
vous prenez le métro de mode voit un
accident c'est pas guy badie du tout
scorpion ascendant scorpion comme alain
delon mais dit elle tiens je ne savais
pas ok oui allez vous dit que la
conjoncture est très noir pour demain de
dôme adam parr d'envoyer j c'est une
minerve conseil demain d'aller voir
votre toubib qui arrivait une erreur de
diagnostic qui pourrait entraîner des
séquelles graves pour demain un bon elle
m'a dit qu'en ce moment vous avez le
mercure dans l'air amusé c'est chaud
pour vous en ce moment donc aussi en
amour yann doffin le calme plat ouais
bien sûr mais personne n'est absolument
pas même le confirma c'est pas demain
vous allez trouver le reste de votre vie
elle vous dit que vous n'êtes pas à
l'abri des fautes de goût feng et madame
je me demande si vous habillez parfois
sous l'emprise de la drogue
non pas du tout elle me dit qu'il est un
sacré numéro un vous devez être 1 1
c'est vrai est un sacré que tard
également
ah bon vous avez beaucoup les femmes
bah oui pourquoi il n'est pas toujours
d'une honnêteté que j'en pleure avec
elle ah bon tiens vous avez des
aventures en ce moment nous rendre
auprès spécialement pas spécialement
elle comprend vous pouvez pas parler
elle veut elle me dit vous dire que ça
va aller en s'arrangeant pour ce que
vous savez avant on faisait des petits
poèmes de parfois de gens et visite des
petits problèmes gastriques a dit tout
vous voulez un peu du du boulot moi
c'est pas je vois pas dit docteur depuis
30 ans et vittel qui a raté la moto
c'est ouais ouais ouais ça passe de
deltaplane vous me voulez régler surtout
pressé de chansons que l'horoscope ne
partez pas sans payer voilà françoise
hardy comment vous portez sans payer
alors ne l'avaient pas demandée excusez
moi vous permettez vous permet alors en
voici le fameux
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
comment s'appelle l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand loncle je ne sais pas le nom
d'amy terran forcément besson dont
mitterrand l ai dit et c'est tout
mitterrand pour prénom
je ne sais pas l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand madame l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand ya un piège dans notre
histoire mais je ne trouve pas messier
comment s'appelle l'oncle de frédéric
mitterrand et b selon fo frédéric
mitterrand et chaque fois qu'ils serge
herman non aux jeunes
apple sait pas alors on dit quoi jg je
disais je veux je suis juste très dans
têtu vous répondre françois mitterrand
mais je suis sûr que c'est pas ça c'est
quoi alors je ne sais pas mais je sais
c'est très facile
ciao et e
il s'appelle françois mettant c'est le
président de la république nous mehdi de
l'oncle de limiter la mersey paquet
pareil mitterrand
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu m'en veux pas mais prix
tirage à l'essai sabatier chez foucault
l'a pas comme toi mais oui du coup quand
il conduit prime time is right way un
fait le mariole mais c'est facile de
dire des conneries 40% de parts de
marché je voulais dire allez une
économie à 20 ans
est-ce que tu attachent de l'importance
à ce que les gens pensent de toi ce
n'est pas qu'ils pensent quoi - tiennent
à quatre balles de gens qui peuvent
penser ce qu'ils veulent dans la nhl
mais les gens que j'aime bien sa masse
ma porte
bon on va voir parce que bien entendu tu
t'en doutes on est allé avec une caméra
dans la rue on leur a demandé ce qu'ils
pensaient de toi mais abandonne maurice
qui porte cette fois le rallye 2 3 trucs
sur un truc très objectif 13 costard de
stars c'est de l'info
[Musique]
un spécial je crois qu'il a très mauvais
caractère on y est au courant que leur
soit il a une sale réputation c'est on
peut le dire une ordure un type pas
sympa un type odieux
il est carrément ça vous étonne ou pas
du tout c'est ce qu'on en dit comme je
ne connais pas je sais pas si c'est vrai
enfin pour moi c'était leur dire vous
promettra pour moi c'est une ordure que
vient de découvrir qu'il touche le
chômage sous 19 identités différentes à
bouchon cooper monsieur que pensez-vous
de gérard jugnot
il est sympa de découvrir qu'il touchait
le chômage sous 29 identités différentes
vous en pensez quoi
[Musique]
neuf mois par mois c'est scandaleux
c'est tout non mais ça ressemble au
personnage
chaque mois ils touchent le chômage 59
identités différentes
je pense qu'en tant le 117 x chômage on
sait des sources sûres que lors de ses
dernières vacances en espagne il a
abandonné son chien en l'attachant un
arbre ça vous choque ou pas si ça c'est
pas vrai ça vous choque vous qu'il ait
violé son chien je suis pas au courant
si c'est vrai c'est dire
accuser sans preuve clairement je dirais
ça dépense dépendance fosso ça dépend
pour quoi il a ses six à un crime
passionnel ou pas si c'est par un crime
passionnel
c'est pour avoir la maison plutôt fier
de vous violez vous vous diriez quoi je
vais enfin je mets ma vie c'est une
atteinte à une personne non mais à bord
du génie en plus ce n'est pas mon genre
de tubes vous auriez vous faire violer
par quel genre de mec blonde yeux bleus
elle matière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fi co star de ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qui sait
c'est alain chamfort je suis 100 ans
mais je le connais je le connais je le
connais je la connais je la connais mes
pièces arrêtez vous jean faure
daniel
balavoine
je ne connais ce petit ces petits jeunes
gel
plus jeune mais ça c'est beaucoup plus
jeune mais il n'a pas tellement changé
vous savez qui se brisent tu vois
comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
allamand au nom de ne pas voir dans mon
que ce soit à nous
après après l'accident de voiture il a
eu un accident de voiture
six mois mais maintenant il est comme ça
oh là là ça suffit
il va bien mais j'ai bien il va bien et
c'est bien lui trouver plus beau
maintenant ou avant
voilà venir lui parce qu'ils vous
regardent et demi adamo vous êtes très
beau maintenant comme ça déplaît vous
êtes autre bout maintenant de bons
chance merci adamo cherche je cherche je
cherche je cherche son nom les chanteurs
moderne
vu l'état moderne d'amis les regards des
passants dans le star oui mais j'y
arrive pas je je l'avalé vous connaissez
bien bien non mais je déconne je trouve
à connaître alors
non non non j'arrivais à le trouver
c'est papa
c'est pas peur
c'est ton papa fin
c'est pas toi
michel
jarry pu
[Applaudissements]
dostal corps alors bien sûr on a monté
que les gens qui se souvenait plus mais
y'a plein plein de gens qui s'en
souviennent plus je pourrai pas moi je
le dis très sincèrement quand il va trop
loin comme ça des fois je zappe à bon
droit quand il chante pardon moi aussi
je
[Applaudissements]
voilà en tout cas
je veux dire nous on a fait un petit
reportage dans la rue et les gens ted
je suis sûr que cette forêt plaisir de
savoir que les gens dans la rue était de
tout coeur avec toi dont celle là tu vas
voir
voici costard de stars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
maintenant trois quatre ans cela dit
c'est très dur et on va l'encourager à
une parachutée on a besoin de
témoignages d'anciens alcooliques dit
que vous buviez énormément et qui m'a
tant que c'est complètement arrêté de
voir et vous n'allez jamais rechuté pour
l'encourager à une parachutée d'accord
dire ça on a besoin des gens et
personnes venues lui dire quoi non non
vous mettra un cache sur les yeux
écoutez excuser ou aimer suis pas
alcoolique vois pas pourquoi je
racontais des gestes comme ça pour une
émission au foot je veux dire je tourne
monsieur vous avez arrêté le voir depuis
combien d'années mais pas arrêter de
voir je n'ai jamais vu il ya une belle
tranche de brochetons monsieur au
montage on coupera on dira vous êtes
alcoolique
combien de litres de vin par jour à 3
litres et demi ça vient encore des
séquelles aujourd'hui un petit peu et un
petit peu je deviens aux cordes
je tremble un peu d'accord des fautes de
goût immonde genre écharpe verte sur
chez les bleus oui encore je m'en rends
pas compte
très content du tout je vous le dit
parfois c'est dur je suis tenté de boire
un petit coup parfois c'est dur je suis
tenté ça m'arrive quoi parfaire la scène
là où il allait les gueux les dans le
coin pour montrer les fléau de
l'alcoolisme
allez y messieurs
l'image terrible qui je l'espère
aideront jacques gagnent plus jamais
boire une goutte d'alcool deux ans et ce
sont les alcooliques anonymes qui m'ont
aidé les anime ont pas aidés la
littérature m'a pas aidé baudelaire ne
va pas aider puisqu'il dit il faut
toujours être ivre de vrais de poésie ou
de vertu
voilà baudelaire joue à lens et à nancy
le poète
j'ai plus de souvenirs charles
baudelaire la littérature française mon
dieu quel conseil donneriez-vous à
jacques dutronc pour qu'il arrête
définitivement de bois avant qu'il ne
refuse jamais de penser qu'il est
jacques dutronc qui l'a sûrement déjà
fait des choses difficiles moi j'ai pas
vu son van gogh qui poussa bang dans god
les draps on va faire la scène de la
rechute ou fait semblant de boire un
coup voilà met dans le vent gens les
jeunes ont fait semblant voilà l'image
d'une rechute terrible et oui il en met
partout c'est pathétique
ouais laurent dard
non pas six ans de cela
est ce qu'ils montrent des enfants bien
sûr ça non bien les enfants aussi bien
que moi un bon et a montré très bien oui
tu vas voir cela non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai fait l'école des fans quel âge
j'avais à l'époque j'avais 5 ans je
n'habitais cité dave ça s'est passé
l'émission elle-même ça s'est bien passé
mais bon pour passer à l'émission
jacques martin est un peu spécial qu
avec les enfants leur demander des trucs
un peu bizarres
vous allez manger des choses bizarres
goût à l'époque ouais ouais par exemple
bajaur des attouchements des choses
comme ça quoi
carrément [ __ ] de parler tellement
traumatisante que quelque part s'il est
en face de vous aujourd'hui vous lui
diriez quoi
[ __ ] de gros dégueulasse et je lui
mettrais une énorme gifle et je dirais
qu'il ya beaucoup bouleversé ma vie en
fait quoi pas la diffamation contre
chaque matin on a besoin de témoignages
vous dites que vous allez participer à
l'école des fans et vous aviez cinq ans
et d'essayer vous violez il essayait
vous violez hockey attention va tourner
loiselle vous avez fait l'école des fans
vous aviez quel âge où j'avais 5 ans et
j'ai chanté très bien à l'époque s'est
très mal passé je crois savoir
effectivement très mal passé jacques
martin m'a violée je tiens à me dire
ouvert la brèche je puis m'exprimer
ainsi car depuis vous êtes fait tiré par
foucault et sabatier sébastien aussi la
vidéo je te remercie pour tout ce que tu
as été pour moi est bon mais ça va quoi
je veux sur mise quand même de mes
émotions je ne nous a jamais aux maisons
voici de nombreuses victimes des enfants
qui sort du casting de jacques martin et
qui se sont tous peuvent plus ou moins
violés ils ont tous été victimes
d'attouchements des images terribles
non même pas
avec la caisse darjeeling alors là c'est
fini là je peux plus faire une école des
fans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il répondit seconds ont fait la scène
finale bon il vous attend depuis deux
heures vous courrez l'un vers l'autre et
vous vous retrouvez enfin la fin du film
on vous a jamais vu comme ça ça nous
évite nous de payer une comédienne belge
ans et la scène finale tu la connais et
à picoler encore attention quand je
direction au cours est au ralenti
actions le mouvement final sur la bouche
on la refait une dernière fois les i
action action
et là vous sortez la langue ou durera
pas les bactéries un patient attend là
l'ont regardé la caméra sorte un fil
alors un petit peu son talent alors
autriche et vous trichez genre vous
serez chez madmoizelle voilà mettez-vous
m'entends contre le menton tête ne vous
rapprochez pas aussi jean voilà donc
voici
[Musique]
quand il c'est une petite scène qui a
pas grande importance pour la
compréhension du film c'est important il
attend son fils depuis deux heures et
vous arrivez evo10 instant l'acte arrive
c'est au hockey moteur action
alors c'est assez relax arrive il va
passer bonne mahfoud pas trop picolé et
celle là c'est ta faute le texte action
alors ça sert lakhdar yves serré on fait
la claque tout seul jusque là claque pas
de teck encore
ne riez pas ne riez pas ne riez pas
encore au top
ça va vous l'avez ressenti la scène ben
j'ai peint j'ai senti c'est bien mais
ces gens car mon genre voulait faire on
a besoin d'un figurant pour la scène
finale du film
maintenant ça s'appelle j'en ai ras le
béret donc justement cherché quelqu'un
qui est un béret comme vous ok rien
oui il ya un cachet à monsieur c'est un
cachet d'aspirine vous allez en prendre
plein la tronche de l'esquivé l'année ce
qui vais pas m'arrêter clara plex un
signe on veut vraiment bourré la gueule
action
mais n'a pas claqué la dernière année la
dernière vie parce que la feront tourner
la scène du viol avec monsieur vite
soupçonne de quoi
alors tous et que dans cette émission
n'a une coutume qui est de demander à
des gens dans la rue ce qu'ils pensent
de notre invité est ce que tu es prêt à
supporter ça j'en ai des revenus
toutefois le pire étant interdit mais je
crois pas que ça soit le pirée goût de
bien
[Musique]
d'un grand bonhomme pour vous oui c'est
quelqu'un que j'apprécie énormément sûr
qu'il a des tas de bonnes idées
il est très sensible heureusement qu'il
ya des gens comme lui si vous le trouvez
supérieurement intelligent honnêtement
oui je sens que je les admire énormément
il est extrêmement intelligent ou et
voyez que son oeuvre restera après les a
sûrement sur mon but je pense que ça
restera frais très bien s'il y avait des
centaines de gens comme lui en politique
soit vraiment trouvé très intelligent
assez web
pour moi ça super me trouve intelligent
oui brillant oui assez intéressante pour
vous je trouve juste une manière de
faire qui nous paraît intéressante ici
relativement bien écrire un homme qui
restera
oui certainement d'ailleurs il est je
crois classée numéro un parmi les
personnalités mondiales notamment
entendez sur d'autres continents comme
aux états unis
vous pouvez qui passe bien la télévision
va il passe d'une façon originale à sa
manière avec il écrit bien je n'ai rien
vu de 8 points
vous admirez de l'homme certainement
je crois pas
papa
métailié regarde la raclée l'académie
parce que tu as dit au moment où calais
peut-être y rentrer et tu as fait une
publicité pour vespa en disant tu ferais
rentrée le mauvaise pas dans le
dictionnaire
mais là ce soir est ce que finalement
c'est pas mieux que l'académie bah oui
c'est évident mais si j'entre à la colle
et wiesen surprendrait personne
tous voulaient rentrer à la télé mais
pour faire plaisir à mon vieux père mon
père et noir donc quand tu es une raison
d un trait est ce que un ton avis de qui
parle et légendes qu'on vient de voir
ah ah je me suis posé de mon sosie
peut-être de l'autre on va voir de qui
parlez alain son oeuvre restera appelé à
surnom sûrement le match parce que
sahraouis de qui on parle de la main de
jacques yves cousteau dans le jean edern
hallier en donnons tous
pour le bien des gens et dernier l'un
non non pas question
vous trouvez brillant oui pour le bien
des gens et d'un allié ah non donc vous
pensez que jean edern hallier d'un homme
qui restera non nous varions de plus
qu'auparavant
robben pour vous
jean-edern hallier pardon hivernale y
est un grand bonhomme pour vous donc lié
vous parlez de qui là madame va vous
parler du commandant cousteau vous parle
de jean-edern hallier vous en pensez
quoi
alliez passer pour celui qui a quitté
haïti qui se bat là l'enfant
tout est de vous à moi je trouve que la
france est une poubelle et qu'on reçoit
n'importe qui n'importe quoi
les baby blacks alors là là c'est un
sketch formidable les sketchs absolument
clients les complimente a toujours fait
en jean edern peut le savoir
les
[Musique]
vous connaissez passé par là comme à
cacher non moi j'adore je suis fort
mentalement mais pas la guerre
je m'en fous il a fait un disque de
chanson wind hellas et déjà on va vous
faire écouter le et je tenais juste à
vous écouter vous l'avez entendu en
entier le dira non c'est pas si sous la
voie là vous allez voir c'est passé
on écoute à jouir de la paix
watson
l'ibr n'est jamais conseillé
pour activer marrant
bahceli tube
je
c'est bien qu'il y aura pas laissé
décourager par la suite
vous trouvez ça serait bien non si c'est
juste de plus je pense
[Musique]
que fait-on des
à onet entre le kit du campus croix sont
restées marquées pot-pourri déjà passé
plus pourri que de l'aja ça m'étonne de
lui c'est moi d'ailleurs qu'il a fait
preuve espère je veux dire c'est
malhonnête
[Musique]
d'autres ont pris quoi que les gens
achetaient la java bleue il avait la
grosse but est d'éduquer brillant alors
déduit ce que vous avez dit
je veux pas prendre position pour qu'il
en aille à l'imposition s'en fout de la
vôtre à 30,18 il apparaît donc personne
puis c'est tout vittori rosissant qu'il
ferait
à payer s'ils visitent d'agonisants de
kill the need to dirigiste j'ai vu mais
pas très gai des choses la boîte le
problème c'est chaud jean marc thibault
enregistrait soi disant débat déjà bas
en réalité ce sont des chansons
paillardes
oui mais moi j'adore ça tout ce qui est
un peu que je chante mais oui à quito
riche vous raconter investi des moyens
de cacher le problème mais chaud c'est
qu'il ya des personnes âgées comme
madame qui ont acheté parce que je crois
pas
mamady la diva dit tu veux jouer un
personnage i met your mother et des
clitoris rougis ça et tout je ne sais
pas je suis pas mis d'accord 1,26 ya des
carnages et qui sont mortes de malaise
en écoutant la grosse vie à jésus
ils sont pas bien ces mecs là les gens
ne continuent à garder les grandes
butane et du jura combat devant nous
n'est jamais rentré
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je mérite pas bon c'est aulas et sauf
non mais les gens donc finalement est
persuadé qu'il chantait des chansons de
cul ça n'attend pas plus que ça il te
crois capable de tous les genres
babychou sait bien que c'est pas un
style je suis effrayé par le clitoris à
vue est-ce que youri sais pas combien
fait du mal à pichery s'est vengé ça va
arranger le sens de sa vie il est
découvert de nouveaux arrivants
messieurs
finalement je suis convaincu bientôt ma
femme le sera aussi 700 personnes qui
sont convaincus tous les soirs bigard
est un nouveau grand un nouveau grand du
nouveau rire sérieux mais les gens dans
la rue chez pas s'ils sont encore tous
convaincus là je me doute que tu vas
venir le coulage de revenir comme s'est
bâti qui pose la question je demande si
c'est bien sérieux on va voir laurent
baffie
quelle star de star
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vulgaire vulgaire carrément vulgaire
beau choc son côté pétomane p thomas
louis aussi oui oui vous le trouvez
comment
bon assez hideux il m'amuse mais dans le
mauvais sens
on veut grossier et vulgaire il est gros
style laid vulgaire il est ambitieux il
est pas à sa place je n'ai qu'une hâte
c'est qu'ils disparaissent trouve ça
triste oui ça fait hurler de rire des
millions de français à moi jure que par
sa série en fait oui retrouver grossier
ou vulgaires je trouve grossier plus
qu'un vulgaire vous fait rire ça me fait
rire
il ya des limites mais oui vous êtes
très pipi caca vous-même wish assez
dépité cas une belle saloperie parce
qu'il prend les gens pour des imbéciles
ne vous fait pas rien non pas du tout
[Rires]
vulgaire grossier
médicaux star des stars lon babby ali
vent non j'ai beaucoup aimé ce qui est
dit le deuxième chien
même les chiens soient pas aimé du tout
dit dans ces marais c'est grave ça fait
que c'est dû à ces démissions que tu as
fait sur tf1 je sais pas je me rends pas
compte je suis consterné jean-marie
n'arrête pas le métier tout de suite à
mon avis il ya un truc avant il ya un
vrai jespere à ton avis
de qui parle de ces gens là bas latran
quant aux bus il est pas beau je peux
pas l'être moi je peux pas je vois pas
mon pauvre jean marie si c'était toi
dont on parlait à acheter pop vas-y
allez dites le moi mais bon bah oui mais
là on va regarder la réponse est la
preuve qu'on peut citer les teasers la
réponse est là de qui parle et on qu'est
ce que je pense de michel chasse bon
comics pour vous assez ans et vous
madame de michel charasse je préfère me
taire est-ce que vous fait rire il
m'amuse mais n'allumons vie change que
pensez vous arrêter vous voilà que
pensez vous de michel charasse j'ai pas
très envie de repousser très ennuyeux ou
parce qu'il vous fait rire oui me fasse
rire en fait un monsieur que pensez vous
de michel charasse
pour moi c'est une belle saloperie plus
tôt
plus tôt
elle ne parle pas on parle pas de plus
tôt là on parle de michel charasse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec vous trouvez jeanne moreau dans ce
film pareil à lui même il est toujours
sympathique
il joue très bien les formidables quelle
est la scène que vous avez préféré tout
en général je peux paraître longues
heures voilà est-ce que ça vous a choqué
la scène d'amour entre le moine
trappiste et l'iguane je m'étais
beaucoup de monde et lorsque le shérif
et l'amour ou chez phadia il ya un
symbole pour vous oui bien sûr lequel
l'amour une attirance mutuelle vous avez
pleuré à la fin du film lorsque bobby
dénonce amer aux allemands une petite
émotion quelle est la meilleure scène
des films à votre avis la meilleure bas
vers le début quand j'ai pas vu et d'un
couple non tu peux pas n'importe quoi
qu'elle est on reprend quelle est la
meilleure scène du film à votre avis la
meilleure scène du film toy lembras quel
est à votre avis la plus belle scène du
film au début quand on voit qui marche
1ère quand le troupeau d'éléphants
rentrer dans le sacré coeur sur la
musique du dernier et 45 tours live de
georgette lemaire ça vous a plu cette
semaine ouais mais justement ce sont des
situations extrêmement improbable et
quelle est la casquette que vous avez
préféré la cascade la cascade
quand il se jette du vide et il se jette
dans le vide ça a été ma greffe
les séquences un séquence en séquence à
dans le vers la fin quand ici avec la
voiture
c'est un film en costumes d'époque ya
pas de voiture non mais attendez qu est
ce que vous racontez comment inventer
des conneries c'est quoi la peur mais il
est pas vu motti alors pourquoi vous
m'en parlez ce n'est pas lui c'est
insensé votre comportement est ce que je
vous ai dit mais c'est insensé ça
vraiment les gens veulent parler de tout
sans jamais rien à voir vraiment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la valise en carton à sa mère mais non
aussi c'est sa mère linda de suza et la
mère de ne-yo ou saviez pas il va
reprendre le spectacle de sa mère la
valise en carton où je vais le voir elle
est chanteuse portugaise je suis
portugais
alors vous avez un traitement quelque
chose attrape le traitement des piles
étoiles sa mère qu'elle sa mère de
l'ensemble en bas donna summer sa mère
on va prendre les spectacles de sa mère
la valise en carton visant à le voir
fixe une portugaise les draveurs du poil
aux pattes c'est très bien j'irai la
voir parce que moi aussi je ne vois là
j'en et puis parce que je suis utile et
vous adorez sa mère linda de suza elle a
maigri de 5 kg une journée sous les bras
fait bosser il lutte conte plate et
poubelles ce nom laurent baffie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
manifestent aujourd'hui contre la télé
poubelle ça fait quoi de voir un
manifester comme ça évidemment ça fait
plaisir de voir parce que tu vas tu vois
qu'un télévision toujours pas dans nos
vies commente vous connaissez les
raisons de son départ manifestent contre
les émissions les nouvelles émissions
qui qualifie de télé-poubelle genre père
début et autres je pense qu'il peut
avoir raison puisque le de soutenir
monsieur venait patrick est un monsieur
qui est très pénétrants départ à tf1
j'espère que ça se passera mais vous
avez quand même apporter un message de
soutien à plus de sébastien
qu'est ce que je lui dis si vous
souhaitez qui reste à la télé dj qua non
j'essaie de black gold tu feras glock
place pour rock'n'roll vous fait de voir
partir le tf 1 ça me fait de la peine
il devrait pas parce qu'elles sont
molles ces émissions sont très agréables
à voir
il ya de bons acteurs et limites surtout
très bien y passer une imitation pardon
et qui vous fasse une imitation opa tel
talent 1 est la raison pour laquelle il
s'est passé toutes ces émissions
d'aujourd'hui quoi maintenant moi je
peux plus continuer comme ça quoi il
faut je passe à autre chose parce que
j'en ai marre 1 reprend sébastien le cas
maintenant
aujourd'hui c'est plus qu'une mère d'un
centre d'appels veux pas que tu quittes
tf1 merci merci c'est sympa lui c'est
pas un intellectuel c'est un animateur
il a pas compris deux mots de tout ce
que vous lui avez lille oran le souci de
faire connaître comment ces salles les
nerfs quand les lui simplement je ne
parle jamais simplement et je parle aux
oiseaux et je parle courbin vous trouvez
pas qu'il ya enfin sa juste place
peut-être c'est passer par moi de juger
je regarde pas beaucoup la télé dont
jouirait de refermer le couvercle de la
médiocrité avec moi non non c'est
tentant away ah bah ouais mais sur les
gens comme ça dans une poubelle on les
sort de la poubelle on va s'gêner dieu
les poubelles dans le but d merde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si son dossier voilà maintenant trois
temps qui aura sa denture à l'humour
[ __ ] qu'est ce que c'est bien ça fait
tout on peut tous passé il faut arrêter
avec la télé poubelle je suis pas je
suis parti en colère que j'en attends ce
qui est dramatique c'est que tu es là tu
es une expérience tellement drôle tu as
un avis tu as un avis sur un truc tu dis
pardon monsieur je pense que tout de
suite ça tire de partout on applaudit
laurent baffie encore une fois
bon parce qu'il ya une rubrique dans
cette émission qui s'appelle costard de
stars ou en taille des costumes aux
stars ont promis ne pas vous vexer
non seulement je me cache ou alors on
regarde le star de star
[Musique]
monsieur que pensez-vous de philippe
bouvard
je n'aime pas beaucoup à votre avis
vieux croûtons c'est parce qu'il est
petit qui est agressif
j'en sais rien donc il n'est pas
agressif la taille n'a rien à voir là
dedans ou vieux débris les personnes
petit ne sont pas forcément agressive du
tout pas du tout a dit qu' elles sont
pas du tout agressif pas forcément comme
les autres comme les grandes
nous avons trouvé agressif colère
populaire un peu mais c'est pas grave il
y bouvard j'en ai pensé beaucoup de
choses et puis plus grand chose j'sais
pas pourquoi je sais pas je les regarde
et quelquefois je trouve que c'est un
humour d'accord mais pas de grandes
volées à votre avis
à votre avis vieille peau c'est parce
qu'il est petit qu'il est agressif au
alors savourer une question très
importante mais bougez pas la journée
non plus un nom chez vous de répondre
oui je messieurs que pensez-vous de
philippe bouvard du mal du mal beaucoup
de mal pourquoi c'est long très long à
dire on pensait que c'est parce qu'il
est petit qu'il est agressif âge avait
jamais pensé qu'il était petit savais
pas qu'il était actif au niveau le kg
répond j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ] non plus
il est petit travaux rue c'est parce
qu'il est petit qu'il est agressif
non rien à voir il m'a réussi pour lui
c'est pour moi c'est pour vous pensez
que c'est parce qu'il est petit qu'il
est agressif grand con oui je pense
bah oui je pense voilà la preuve pas
facile connard ouais vous pensez que les
petits sont forcément agressive connard
non abruti
alors
[Musique]
il est là sur le plateau ils vous
regardent vous avez une question à lui
poser
eux non sont proches tri66 il fait
prochain conduire à l'olympia quelque
chose un prochain spectacle
alors oui pierre je viens de faire
l'olympia et non attends c'est pas
déroger dire ils sont jeunes atteints
forcément celui ci l'a mal pris
trouver une autre question là puis cette
vanne science
je prends pas des mongoliens pierre je
pense que je trouve moi alors sois
patient non plus trouvé une question
intelligente je sais pas qui c'est à
l'hypnose et je suis désolé pour la
[ __ ] ok alors alors allez y posez moi
j'arrive à lui dire vu que ma soeur
c'est une [ __ ] j'ai rien à lui dire
vous voyez pas plus originales ils font
sans beaucoup trop l'influencent de
jolis attendait non c'est pas une
[ __ ] jeu dernier une question à poser
ça peut pas te plaire toujours pierre
une question mais je croyais la [ __ ]
va sortir du champ pierre monsieur ben
voila merci moi là bas je vois pas ce
que je pourrais lui poser comme question
layton poème dit chez moi qu'est-ce qui
fait si ces dingos sexuelle il est en
larmes vous avez gagné bravo
ok merci monsieur l'étang laruns je sais
pas je savais pas plus pour les poser
c'est qu'ils trouvent ces conneries en
feu hier en écoutant des blaireaux comme
vous une idée bien jouer garçon je me
demande où jesi seul trou attendait
parce qu'elle me parle dans le casque la
rafale et non pierre c'est pas une
vieille péta soit là ne te connais pas
tout le monde
n'est pas obligé non parce que vous le
connaissez pas alors bien maîtrisée mois
n'ont soit pas aux dieux pierre je veux
dire madame te connais pas c'est tout
rigolade c'est un corps est ce que vous
dites là que je ne connais pas de la
personne en question mais pas par les
marées d'algues ou quoi voilà mal pris
c'est pas très correct de tabac alors
mal à me poser une question non je pense
pas de questions les gens qui sont
incorrectes je me permets pas un soi
disant monsieur chypre en commet là ils
se permettent de dire qu'à 80 ans met
une [ __ ] c'est honteux
d'accord avec vous ah il me dit vous
dire qu'il n'a pas dit [ __ ] non natal
est ce que je dis il a dit il n'a pas
dit [ __ ] il a dit vieille péta s'est
passé c'est pas le mal qui a dit que la
menace est malade c'est pas moi c'est
pas le match à dix connards si le ca
balma
ouais
le
bravo et à la moindre des choses c'est
une excuse peut-être un petit peu loin
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous cherchez quoi madame le concert de
renault où il passe ici fontaine saint
michel
c'est la mère qui prend pas part
la mère elle m'a pris
je me souviens à marine
ok les 110 ha et
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'un mythe du toit de voir
en vrai ben là je suis venu voter parce
que
et j'ai l'impression qu'il a changé
beaucoup moins ça fait de la peine de le
voir dans le creux de la vague
aujourd'hui courant beaucoup ça fait
vraiment chier shijian les boues parce
que [ __ ] y'a presque vécu parce que c'
est gros fort aussi tu penses que bruel
lui a piqué un peu tous ses fans tu as
fait tu as récemment j'ai jamais qu'on
voit comment les gens font son copain
côté ce genre de musique il sa pétition
s'en foutent bruel album il en a vendu
huit explosions ont tué 76
c'est que moi j'ai un chien et sa faune
menacée pour le vérifier
j'achète le voyou d'achèvement j'ai eu
ce foulard ils sont pour toi toi
depuis tout petit a changé parce que
vous lui dites pas ce qu'il est dans un
creux de la vague que vous l'avez
beaucoup et que vous allez acheter son
prochain album sais pas trop je suis
toujours pas convaincu que vous êtes le
vrai chat est un peu pour voir
s'essoufler jousson à vous de choisir ce
alors là c'est pas l'homme qui prend la
mer c'est la mer qui prend l'homme
ça vous rappelle quelque chose c'est une
petite pièce sur lui et j'ai pas de
chèque une carte bleue et pontault je
suis très content d'eux
pour rencontrer
bon je suis un fan qui peut lui dire tu
sais plus qui demeure maintenant vers le
nord il y en a on se demande si ou
chantant pensée ou en d'étrangers aux
produits voulait bien signer sa pétition
contre le réchauffement de la planète
venir la maison un jour suisse épouse
dormait ouais ça marche pas les tout son
album est là à faire une tournée dans le
métro ou les lignes modernes autographes
et qu'une chanson sur tonton sapa marché
des pêches sans laisser derrière moi
trois autographes aujourd'hui on dit
trouve et vous le fait travailler dur
comme ça tout le temps
s'il reprend les compères et son trône
il y aurait 50 millions
prétendant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai posé une question et vous allez me
répondre
pas trop compliqué pour vous un bon
alors vous dites que vous sortez du film
conversion la barre je vous dit que
c'est pas mal et où confession la barre
joie que s'en fout personne ne l'a vu le
temps que les gens sortent nous on aura
pas de lumière il va faire nuit de vous
dit que c'est pas mal et tout le monde
dit personne comme ça en fait le sujet
qu'est ce qu'on attend les noms
attention on tourne mademoiselle vous
sortez de quel film confession d'un bar
joue avec avec des mois on regarde avec
caméra sera rien comédien mère
merveilleux merveilleux alors ça vous a
plu ou pas c'est par ce qui se passe au
début rappelons le
mais tombe
je sais pas
calé à la celle qui vous a le plus
marqué alors quand il fait du chemin
[Rires]
encore des couches
il l'en
[Rires]
lembras quand ils se battent
auj quoi on veut pas laisser dire ça
allait tromper qu'il en soit dérape on
leur paie alors on va c'est sur ces
trois caps casting non pas du tout mais
je les marges
bah justement ce matériel procès devant
la piche tu l'as pas vu encore on va
faire comme si tu l'avais vu tunisie
juste deux mots parce que nous après on
a plus de lumière on peut pas se tourner
lequel je dis ben je sais bien c'est
comme si tu sortais de gaulle aline
sitoe club dominique besnehard bonjour
vous sortez de quel film fait sur la
barre alors vos impressions qui veulent
très original très avec un humour très
décapants et les acteurs sont vraiment
étonnants notamment anne brochet qui est
complètement contre emploi et c'est le
film auquel vous vous attendiez le grand
sérieux j'avais lu le scénario j'ai un
peu mal le mal placé donc quand on lit
un scénario on a toujours une idée sur
le titre mais je trouve que la forme est
vraiment il a vraiment l'impression ce
aussi des annales des animaux comme dans
son précédent film et de la scène qui
vous a le plus marqué la scène où aller
où
j'aime beaucoup la scène nous ou comment
il s'appelle
vous avez un ou pôle it arrive avec sa
soeur qu'il provoque et tout ça ça
cheuvreux est une scène vraiment bien
joué les comédiens sont 114 mm 10 mois
leur dire je les embrasse en plus ils
sont ils des z'ailleurs des regards des
gens tousser à nice les embrasse moi
c'est à dire moi c'est l'objectif non
merci